so Hero Zero is a superhero that has one
of the coolest stories that you've never
heard of check this out so this guy kind
of looks like a cross between Iron Man
and Ultraman the Japanese superhero that
fights giant monsters but regardless
Hero Zero is a 13 year old kid named
David McRae who's given his powers by an
alien computer that's embedded in his
chest now hero Zero's powers include
flight superhuman strength and speed
along with heat vision but his most
notable ability is that he can grow to a
height of 300 feet and so this guy's had
a few adventures and fights over the
years but the most notable by far is his
fight with Godzilla which happens when
David is attending San Diego Comic-Con
and Godzilla attacks which sounds
amazing but David battles Godzilla and
then realizes that he has no chance of
actually beating him so he flies him out
to the middle of the ocean to get him
away from the city but in doing so
exhaust all his power and has to be
rescued by the Navy which drives him to
never want to be a superhero again make
sure you guys follow for more